well good afternoon we start with a new
UK record temperature that has been set
this afternoon at Heathrow Airport
40.2 degrees was recorded and
temperatures could still climb further
later this afternoon when it comes after
The Met Office issued a red extreme heat
warning across England that stretches
from London to Manchester and York the
sweltery heat has already caused
significant disruption to the Travel
network with the public being warned not
to venture out unnecessarily and Coast
Guard teams have today rescued five
people and are still searching for a
missing man after an incident at clacton
Pier today in a few minutes time I'm
going to be speaking to our weekly
climate show presenter Tom Heap about
why he is not celebrating this new
record well the Met Office says a
provisional temperature of 40.2 degrees
Celsius was reached at Heathrow and
temperatures are continuing to rise as I
was saying expected to exceed 41 degrees
Celsius
well plenty of reaction to that unwanted
record to come first though let's speak
to Skye's meteorologist Joanna Robinson
who's standing by for us in West London
um Joe it is a record that we didn't
want to break but here it is talk to me
about the picture across the UK so far
today
I can't believe we're saying we've
reached 40 degrees Celsius in the UK it
really is quite incredible and scary and
well focused we've been saying for some
time now that we could see temperatures
as high as this today so and we have
reached that 40 degree mark it is a new
record for the UK but there's other
places across the UK that are seeing
exceptionally high temperatures it's not
just here in London at Heathrow where
we've seen 40.2 But widely across
Central and Eastern parts of England
we're seeing temperatures in the mid to
high 30s extremely high values values
we're not used to in the UK so extreme
heat is continuing through today we will
see the temperatures perhaps Rising a
little further this afternoon we could
see 41 degrees Celsius at some point
this afternoon anywhere really from the
southeast London area all the way
further north towards York perhaps in
that zone there we could see 41 degrees
before the day is out and it's been a
record-breaking day it's not only the
high temperatures today but we had
records broken over the night some
places didn't fall below 25 degrees
Celsius so that beat the previous record
that was set back in 1990 so a
record-breaking day not one we wanted
but one that was well focused and we've
known about for some time but things are
changing like I said today's high is
looking to be about 41 degrees Celsius
but cooler conditions are on the way
we're seeing that already across some
western parts of the UK Northern Ireland
and the far Southwest in cooler
conditions than yesterday those
conditions will spread further east
across all parts so tomorrow some places
could see temperatures some 10 degrees
lower than today so a significant
difference it will still be very warm in
places but a lot lower than what we're
seeing today and then we will see those
conditions those temperatures falling as
the week goes on towards Thursday and
Friday as well so some relief on the way
but for now extremely hot and we do
measure temperatures in the shade so
that 40 degrees is a shade temperature
I'm stood in direct sunlight and it's a
lot hotter than that